the Judiciary Committee will come to
order
without objection the chair is
authorized to declare recesses of the
committee at any time we welcome
everyone to today's hearing on lessons
from the Muller report presidential
obstruction and other crimes I will now
recognize myself for an opening
statement just over two years ago
Special Counsel Robert Muller was
charged with conducting a full and
thorough investigation of the Russian
government's efforts to interfere in the
2016 presidential election unquote
including an examination of quote any
links and/or coordination between the
Russian government and individuals
associated with the campaign of
President Donald Trump and any matters
that arose or may arise directly from
the investigation close quote
he concluded in his own words quote
Russian intelligence officers who were
part of the Russian military launched a
concerted attack on our political system
those officers used sophisticated cyber
techniques to hack into computers and
networks used by the Clinton campaign
they stole private information and then
released that information through fake
online identities and through the
organization WikiLeaks we now know that
the Russian government linked that time
to their operation to interfere with our
election to harm the candidacy of
Secretary Clinton and to benefit the
Trump campaign separately the special
counsel concluded the Russian entities
quote engaged in a social media
operation where Russian citizens posed
as Americans in order to interfere in
the election close quote using fake
identities on social media platforms
like Facebook and Twitter these
operatives planned rallies in favor the
president and spread lies about
Secretary Clinton made to look like with
Media again these activities represent a
direct attack on our democratic process
with respect to these two specific up
with respect to these two specific
operations by the Russian government the
special counsel did not find sufficient
evidence to charge Trump campaign
officials with conspiracy against the
United States he did however document at
least 171 contacts between members of
the Trump campaign and transition team
and the Russian government 16
Trump campaign officials are known to
have had direct communications with
Russian agents representatives of the
Trump campaign exchanged emails and
phone calls and held face-to-face
meetings with high-level Russian
government officials Russian oligarchs
and even some of the hackers the special
counsel accused of working to sway the
election there can be no question that
Congress must investigate this direct
attack and our democratic process
I believe that ranking member Collins
agrees that we must do so without delay
in a letter he sent last month he urged
the committee to call Robert Muller to
testify during the Memorial Day recess
if necessary both for the sake of
transparency and quote for the American
public to learn the full contours of the
special counsels investigation close
quote in a letter he sent last week the
ranking member again asked us to examine
quote the threat Russia and other
nefarious actors have played and may
continue to play in our elections close
quote
over the course of the coming weeks this
committee will do just that
we will examine the effects of foreign
influence in our elections I hope that
we will hear testimony from the special
counsel as well but the country cannot
hope to understand the Russian
government's attack on our democratic
system if we do not also investigate who
stood to benefit from that attack and
the extent to which the Trump campaign
may have welcomed it similarly we cannot
fully understand the special counsels
work without also discussing president
Trump's repeated attempts to undermine
it in his report the special counsel
describes 10 separate incidents in which
the president attempted to change the
scope of direction of the investigation
or to end it all too
at one point President Trump ordered
White House Council Don began to fire
the special counsel later he asked me
Gann to write a letter stating that the
incident never happened again said he
would rather resign at different stages
he asked Attorney General Jeff Sessions
to Unruh cues in quotes himself and to
step in to direct the investigation away
from the president's conduct and of
course the president's public statements
about this investigation before and
after before and after the results of
the Miller report are at best at odds
with the evidence laid out in the report
itself there can be no question that
this committee must investigate this
behavior as well today's hearing is the
first in a series of hearings designed
to unpack the work of the Special
Counsel and related matters we have a
responsibility to do this work to follow
the facts where they lead to make
recommendations to the whole house as
circumstances warrant and to craft
legislation that makes certain no
president Democrat a Republican can ever
act in this way again our witnesses
today include three former federal
prosecutors each of whom has
considerable experience weighing the
kind of evidence laid out by the special
counsel in his report and is in demand
in his indictments of 34 individuals
including President Trump's national
security adviser his campaign manager
his deputy campaign manager and his
personal attorney our panel also
includes mr. John Dean who served as
white House Counsel to President Nixon
and who became a critical witness for
prosecutors and congressional
investigators attempting to respond to
President Nixon's attempt to obstruct
the Department of Justice and the FBI we
will rely on the expertise of these
witnesses to help draw our own
conclusions about the findings of the
special counsel and other evidence
before us today we will do so mindful of
the house rules that prevent us from
making inappropriate personal references
to the President to members of this
committee and to other members of
Congress but the rules of decorum in the
House of Representatives are a shield
not a sword the rules are designed to
focus the debate on the facts and the
law and can therefore help us this
that's the findings of the special
council with the seriousness they
deserve the rules are not however an
opportunity to avoid discussing serious
allegations of misconduct altogether I
know that the ranking member and I
disagree on any number of topics
including
on what conclusions we should draw from
the facts laid out by the special
counsel for example in his last letter
he argued that President Trump has been
quote vindicated unquote by the special
counsels report I cannot agree with that
conclusion either I believe with the
special counsel given his insistence
that his report quote does not exonerate
the president close quote
but I also know that the ranking member
and I agree on the seriousness of the
attack on our elections now and that we
must work together to make it more
difficult for any president to ignore
the danger that presented itself in 2016
that work continues in this hearing room
today and that continues that the
Department of Justice later this
afternoon when this committee will begin
to review some of the document documents
that Attorney General Barr previously
denied us I am pleased that we have
reached an agreement to review at least
some of the evidence underlying the
Mullah report including interview notes
first-hand accounts of misconduct and
other critical evidence and that this
material will be made available without
delay to members of the committee on
both sides of the aisle as a result I
see no need to resort to the criminal
contempt statute to enforce our April
19th subpoena at least for now so long
as the department upholds its end of the
bargain but our arrangement with the
department does not extend to the full
scope of our request for the full model
report and its underlying materials
including grand jury information nor
does it extend to our demand that done
began a key fact witness testified
before this committee our work will
therefore continue tomorrow on the House
floor when we consider chairman
McGovern's resolution to authorize this
committee to enforce its subpoena
through civil litigation is my
expectation that as a result of this
authorization mr. McGann will testify
before here before long between now and
then we still have an obligation to
investigate the deeply troubling
evidence outlined by the special counsel
not merely the portions that implicate
Russian Nationals as some have suggested
but the entire report including the
volume that lays out some of the
president's troubling behavior the
committee's work is serious we should
delay it no further we should conduct
ourselves in a manner that is consistent
with the rules of the house and worthy
of this chamber and even if we cannot
agree to draw the same conclusions from
the evidence we should at least proceed
with a common with the common
understanding we were attacked we were
attacked by a foreign adversary
president Trump's campaign took full
advantage of the attack when it came the
descriptions of obstruction of justice
and volume to go to the heart of our
legal system if we can agree on this
common set of facts as our starting
place and agree to follow the facts of
the law where they take us I believe we
can make a great deal of progress in
this hearing today I thank the panel for
being here today and I look forward to
your testimony before we proceed further
I want to note for the record that the
gentlelady from Pennsylvania miss Dean
is unable to be with us today due to a
death in the family she very much wanted
to participate in today's hearing and I
did not want anyone to misinterpret her
absence it is now my pleasure to
recognize the ranking member the
Judiciary Committee the gentleman from
Georgia mr. Collins for his opening
statement
Thank You mr. chairman and I appreciate
especially the last and I would spend my
prayers and thoughts to miss Dean as
well I'm just a little over a little
under a year in fact Monday this week
will be one year from losing my mother
so it is for all of us we go through
that and it's an expression of love
however I will come to this hearing
today and say that we were continuing I
appreciate the Chairman's understanding
I appreciated the Chairman outlying a
great deal of the Masek conclusion that
was an affirmative conclusion from the
Moller investigation that was a the
foreign interference in the Russian part
of this what is amazing though and I
agree with the Chairman's assessment of
being attacked and and there's something
we've known the Russians were always a
part for some of us we've been talking
about the Russians for a long time in
that but it's about priorities and
here's my question about priorities and
coming to this hearing and the question
of priorities
is is if we were attacked as the
chairman just said then the priority
should be to go to the battlefield on
the attack where we were attacked on and
not run by the sideshow to hear from the
commentators we should actually go to
the one that the the mr. Muller actually
said was we have a problem here we're
showing you we've actually inducing
indictments here how can we firm up our
elections how can we do away with
foreign interference how can we do that
it's about priorities and I think what
has happened here is the Chairman is
showing the priorities the priorities
were from November 2016 it appears that
we have an issue with who got elected
president and we thought the Moller
investigation would solve this for us
and it really did not even after a lot
of discussion we're gonna hear a lot
about that today and in the discussion
that we have but he goes back to
priorities and priorities of bringing
what we focus on and how we focus on it
and if you look at the the witnesses
today and you discuss what was actually
just went on fro ha we're not bringing
Russia front and center we're not
bringing the the threats to our election
front and center although I appreciate
the Chairman reading the letters that I
send him and understanding what we could
actually be working on and I'm wanting
to move forward there but however here
we come with some folks that are great
folks you're wonderful on TV I could
catch your testimony on TV in fact by
the way I couldn't this morning I'm a
Republican I believe that you use
everything that you've got there's much
business you won't generate as much as
you want to work for yourself I don't
believe it's the problem of this
committee to have to come in here from
those who are not a part of the Moller
investigation who are not a part of this
pontificating on things that you can do
on TV like all of us get a chance to do
occasionally but not here on the hearing
but then we get and I'm sort of reminded
to rush the priority issue because just
a few years ago it was brought up and
one of our kin has talked about Russia
being a threat and the former president
mr. Obama said you know that the 80s are
asking for their foreign policy by well
guess what this committee is now hearing
from the 70s and